kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz 38 gün
ets4 kampımızın bugün geldik 39 gününe
son gününe artık bitiriyoruz
vedalaşacağız vedalaşmayı videonun
sonunda yaparız oyun sonu charge
Kafamızda bu aynı zamanda 21 günü bugün
doğal afetler olarak bildiğiniz ama
aslında ona afet dememiz gerekiyor
afetler konusunu öğreneceğiz Evet ben
kalemimi aldım hazırım Sende beğen
tuşuna basıp abone olarak hazırladıysan
o zaman ne diyoruz Yunus hoca şöyle bir
defa Öğren Bir de asla unutma gençler
dersin
etlere dur orada dur derse başlamadan
önce ilk önce bir hazır bulunuşluğunun
yüksek olması lazım şimdi Bakın ben size
ta kampın başında ne dedim bazı konular
vardır çok önemlidir Ya zaten 5 soru
çıkıyor bu 5 soruyu da stratejik olarak
çalışman lazım bazı konulara çok önem
vermen lazım bazı konulara İlla konu
atlamayacaksan Bazı konuları da böyle
kabaca bilmen gerekiyor çok fazla not
tutmadan böyle kabaca öğrenmen gerekiyor
dünyanın şekli ve hareketleri konusunda
öyle dıdısının kadar en iyi Car kadar
öğrenme diye seni uyardım 12 soruluk bir
testin 6 tanesini yapman yeterli dedim
sana Sakın Orada yanlış yapınca moralim
bozulmasın pes etme dedim sana neden
çünkü sorularımızın hemen hemen nereden
geldiği belli o konulara Ama iyi öğren
dedim sana bugün öyle bir konudayız
nüfustan soru kaçıramazsın 12 soru varsa
onu üstü yapmak zorundasın bugün
öğreneceğimiz doğal afetlerden soru
kaçırma ihtimalin olmamalı 12 soru varsa
12'de 12 yapacaksın gerekirse o yüzden
çok dikkatli bir şekilde dinleyeceksin
bol bol bulabildiğin kadar soru
çözeceksin Bu dersle alakalı doğal
afetlerle alakalı bugün ders bittiğinde
soru bankamızın kampında 18 eylül'de
başlatıyoruz Belki senin izlerken
başlamıştır bitmiştir bile 18 eylül'de
başlatıyoruz kampını kamp takvimi
Google'da biliyorsunuz linklerim de var
Oraya da ekledim kamp takvimini yine
videonun sonunda gösteririm size ders
biterken bugünkü konuğunuz bugün ders
bittiğinde hangi sayfaları çözeceksiniz
169 170 171 ve 172'yi çözeceksiniz
sadece bu kitabı değil elinizde başka
kaynaklar varsa onun da afetler kısmını
kesinlikle çözün ama bundan da ötv'nin
kitabından bile öteye ogmateryal
yazacaksın internette devletin Sitesi
oraya gireceksin doğal afetler
sorularının hepsini tek tek çözeceksin
Evet anlaştıysak bu konuda iyice bunun
ne kadar önemli bir ders olduğunu
anladıysan o zaman gelin
neden bu derse doğal afetler dersi değil
de afet dediğimizde öğrenelim afetleri
öğreneceğimizi öğrenelim bakın gençler
Biz aslında doğal afetleri bakın doğal
afet afetleri yanlış söyledim Affet Beni
doğal afet ve beşeri afet olarak
ayırıyoruz O yüzden biz bunlara doğal
afet dediğimizde sadece buradaki doğal
afetleri kapsıyor bu kavram o da yanlış
oluyor bizim bunlara ne dememiz lazım
afet dememiz lazım afetler çünkü hem
doğal hem de beşeri olarak ayıracağız
Peki hocam afet ne demek Bak tanımı
ezberleme Ama gel seninle tanımdan tek
tek gidelim bak canlı ve cansız çevreye
zarar veren Demek ki ben bir afet
diyebilmem için buna çevreye Özellikle
de canlılara zarar verecek bu zarar
verme olayının gerçekleşmesi gerekiyor
bir zarar verecek 2 yani hiç kimseye
zarar vermemiş hiçbir şeye zarar
vermemiş bir olay afet olarak
nitelendiriliyor Bunun dışında
insanların normal yaşantısını durduran
ya da kesintiye
an hayatımızda kesintiye uğratma yapacak
hiç umurumuzda olmayan bir şey yaşandı
kutuplarda bu olur mu bu olmaz Bu bir
doğal afet midir Bu bir afet midir Hayır
hiçbir şekilde hiç kimseyi etkilemiş bir
şey etkilemiyor
hiçbir atmıyor Demek ki bizi kesintiye
uğratacak cam ve mal kaybına neden
olacak can ve mal kaybına neden olacak
büyük can ve mal kayıpları göreceğiz
işte Biz bunlara afet diyeceğiz İşte bu
afeti ikiye ayıracağız 1 doğal afet iki
beşeri afet Doğal afetlere bak tanım
yine aynı can ve mal kaybına neden
olacak ağırlıklı olarak ya da tamamen
doğal koşulların neden olduğu afetler
bunlar yani ortada etkili olan ana unsur
doğal koşullar olacak doğal koşullar
etkili olduğunda doğal afet olmuş oluyor
ağırlıklı ya da tamamen derken orada
hani hafif etkisi insanların da etkisi
İllaki vardır Bu doğal afetlerde
hızlandırıcı etkisi vardır gibi ama
burada ağırlık yine doğanın kendisinde
olmuş oluyor Bunun dışında bakın beşeri
afetlere bakın nükleer kazalar biyolojik
kazalar patlamalar gibi asıllı
insanların ortaya çıkarttığı afetleri
kapsıyor buradaki doğal afeti mantığını
öğrendik mi Tamam gelin şimdi bu doğal
afetlerle ile alakalı bilmemiz gereken
bazı şeyleri bakalım ilk olarak burada
insanların bundan etkilenmesi gerekiyor
afetlerden bunu unutmuyorsun Bunun
dışında bir de şu var gelişmiş
gelişmemiş ülkelerde afetlerin etkileri
farklı oluyor gelişmiş ülkelerde afetler
insanları daha az etkiliyor Çünkü onlar
afetlere karşı bilinçliler kendilerini
önceden koruyabiliyorlar önceden
tedbirlerine almışlar ama az gelişmiş ya
da gelişmemiş ülke dediğimiz ülkelerde
doğal afetlerin yıkıcı etkisi daha fazla
oluyor Aynı büyüklükte bir deprem
gelişmiş ülkede daha az insan kaybeden
neden olurken aynı büyüklükteki bir
deprem az gelişmiş ülkede daha fazla
insan kaybına neden olabilir gelişmişlik
Doğal afetlerden etkilenmeyi fazla ya da
az olarak sağlayabiliyor Tamam bunu
unutmuyorsun gelişmiş ülkeler Demek ki
farklı olabiliyor Bir de şu yaşanan
afetler farklı afetlere neden olabilir
Deprem olduğunda bir deprem yaşandı
deprem sonucunda tsunamiye neden
olabilir bu mesela aynı deprem çağı
tetikleyebilir aynı deprem bir heyelan
faaliyetini tetikleyebilir Yani bir
deprem Yani bir afet başka bir afetin
ortaya çıkmasına neden olabilir Bunu da
aklımızda tutalım böyle sorularda
gelebiliyor bize hızlı gerçekleşen
afetlere önlem almak daha zor hızlı
gerçekleşen afetlerden kastığımız ne
şurası bizi Bunun soru olarak da
sorabiliyorlar yani şu hızla bak aniden
gerçekleşen deprem aniden gerçekleşiyor
değil mi buna önlem alabilmek biraz daha
zor olabiliyor mesela açı yine önleme
alınabiliyor bazılarına Tabii ki
alınabiliyor ama önlem alabilmek daha
zor gerçekleşiyor Çünkü aniden
gerçekleşiyor bu önlem almak öncesinde
Tabii ki önlem alabiliriz ama önlem
almak şu yavaş gerçekleşenlere göre daha
zor bakın hangilerini yavaş hangilerinin
hızlı gerçekleştiği senin sınav sorun
olabilir Çünkü o geometeryalde bununla
alakalı soru tarzımız var sana doğal
afetlerden soru sorulacaksa böyle bir
soru çıkabilir karşımıza hangisi hızlı
gerçekleşen hangisi yavaş gerçekleşen
diye bak mantıken sen bunların hepsini
öğrendiğimizde oturacak kafanda deprem
Çığ bir anda gerçekleşiyor Ama bu tarafa
bak şiddetli soğuklar kuraklık kuraklık
sürekli küresel ısınmayla beraber Yavaş
yavaş kuraklıklara gidiyoruz değil mi
kıtlıklar erozyons erozyon hocam Ben
bunları bilmiyorum erozyon falan merak
etme az sonra öğrendiğinde hangisinin
yavaş hangisinin hızlı gerçekleştiğini
sen karar vereceksin bunun dışında bakın
affetleri Biz böyle ayırıyoruz işte
klimatik afetler jeolojik Jeomorfolojik
afetler biyolojik afetler diye
ayırıyoruz Hocam ben bunları böyle tek
tek ezberleyeceğimi ezberlemeyeceksin
mantığını bileceksin nasıl hocam
mantığını bileceğim Şimdi ben her zaman
her derste yaptığım gibi bu tabloyu
öğreneceğiz şimdi seninle beraber en
son tsunaminin ne olduğunu bildiği için
hangisine girebileceğini de sen karar
vereceksin tabloyu Sen kendin
oluşturabileceksin Ama ben sana şimdi
desem ki Tsunami jeolojik afettir desem
tsunaminin ne olduğunu bilmediğin için
bunun altına neden girdiğini mantıken
öğrenemezsin O yüzden bunu en sona
bırakacağız hepsini öğrendiğimizde
kendini zaten yerleştirebileceksin ama
en sonra atlama Çünkü burada biyolojik
afetlerle alakalı çok önemli bir Püf
nokta vereceğim sınavda büyük bir
ihtimalle onu bekliyorum Bu sene
İnşallah unutmam şu tabloya geri dönmeyi
Allah'ım dur ya En sonunda bir not
alayım da unutmayın orayı dur yoksa
unuturum sona geri dön Pardon başa dön
kesin unuturum yoksa çok önemli
unutmamam lazım geldik şimdi depremlere
Aslında bundan önceki konularda Biz
depremleri öğrenmiştik deprem fay
hatlarının nerelerden çizildiğini
görmüştük Türkiye'de de dahil olmak
üzere depremleri nerede olduğunu
görmüştük Şu an aslında senin için bir
genel tekrar gibi bu depremleri daha çok
biz nerede görüyorduk deprem bölgelerini
bir dünya haritasını açtığımızda hemen
açalım o zaman nasıl yapıyorduk depreme
depremi çizmeyi bilirsem birçok şeyi
bilirsin zaten Çünkü depremlerle sıcak
su kaynakları kaplıcalar zengin tarım
arazileri volkanik araziler birçok şey
paralellik gösteriyor ne yapıyorduk
geliyorduk bu kıtanın Batı kıyısını
boydan boya çiziyorduk Batı kıyısını
boydan boya çiziyorduk sonra geliyordu
şuradan Alp dağlarından başlayıp
Himalaya dağlarına doğru uzanan
Endonezya üzerinde şuradan Yeni
Zelanda'ya buradan Japonya'ya uzanan
hattı çiziyorduk Afrika'nın Doğu
kesiminden gelende Vadisi'ni Türkiye'de
birleştiriyorduk bir de şurada Atlas
okyanusunun ortasında bir tane hattımız
vardı bu bizim deprem bölgelerimiz
dünyadaki deprem bölgelerini Bilmem
Aslında buradan çıkacak olan soruyu
çözmenin de sağlayacak Peki hocam
Türkiye'de nerelerde deprem görülür o
deprem haritasında açalım Bu da bizim
deprem haritamız
deprem bölgelerimiz Biz birinci derece
şöyle biraz daha yakınlaştırayım He
şöyle kırmızı olanlara dikkat et
asla ihtimalle daha yüksektir hangisinde
daha azdır diye bakın Kuzey Anadolu Fay
Hattı demiştik Doğu Anadolu fay hattı
demiştik Batı Anadolu Fay Hattı demiştik
Buralar depremlerin yüksek olduğu yerler
biz bu hatlardan ne kadar uzaklaşırsak o
kadar depremden korunmuş oluruz ama Bu
tamamiyle deprem olmaz anlamına gelmiyor
deprem burada buradaki kırık da olsa
bile Etkisi buraya kadar gidebilir Tabii
ki etkisi azalır gücü azalır ama
buralara kadar uzaklaşır Buralara Kadar
etkisine gösterebilir ama şuraya bakın
beyaz olan kısma karavandan Aksaray'a
doğru uzanan şu Hatta deprem olma
ihtimali çok daha düşüktür ne kadar
uzaklaşırsa şu kırmızı hattan Bakın şu
bölgelere uzaklaştığımızda deprem olma
ihtimali azalıyor yine şurada Trabzon'un
reislerinin Artvin'in deniz kenarına
doğru uzaklaştığımızda Kırklareli
Edirne'nin daha Kuzey taraflarına
gittiğimizde deprem olma ihtimali
azalıyor bakın gençler burada iller
verilip hangisini depreme ihtimali daha
azdır ya da bir harita verilip hangisine
depreme ihtimali daha azdır diye
sorulabilir çok da güzel olması gereken
de bir sorudur türkiye’de yaşayan bir
insan olarak senin depremin daha az
nerede olduğunu bilmen gerekiyor böyle
bir deprem haritası verildiğinde onun
mantığına oturtman lazım bu haritayı
oturttuk mu kafanızda Tamam geçelim
dersinize şimdi depremleri demiştik bir
rihder ölçeği vardı değil mi Bir de
merkali ölçeğimiz vardı bunlara göre
ölçüyorduk ve
şunu depremin şiddeti farklı
dır farklıdır
7 büyüklüğünde olabilir mesela deprem 7
büyüklüğünde olabilir ama şiddeti Belki
de 8 büyüklüğünde Olabilir Neden Çünkü
şiddeti etkilenmeyi Aslında ifade ediyor
Çünkü depremlerin büyüklüğü 7
büyüklüğünde olsa bile bazen bazıları
çok derinlerde olabiliyor Onun bize
etkisi daha az olabilir şunu hep
duymuşuzdur yaşadığımız depremden sonra
işte Japonya'da 9 büyüklüğünde bir
deprem oldu Türkiye'de 7 büyüklüğünde
bir deprem oldu Japonya'daki çok fazla
etkilemezken Türkiye'deki çok fazla
etkiledi ve bu Tartışma konusu da
olmuştur bunu mesela tartışmamız lazım
Evet Japonya'daki 9 büyüklüğünde bir
deprem ama o çok daha derinlerde olmuş
ama onun şiddeti de fazladır şiddeti de
fazladır Japonya bundan az etkilenir
Çünkü Japonya'nın yaptığı binalar sağlam
ve dayanıklı binalardır O yüzden
önlemlerini almışlardır önlemleri
alınmış dayanıklı binalar olduğu için
tedbirler alındığı için Japonya'da
ölümler çok az olur dersin en başında
söylediğimiz Şey geliyoruz gelişmiş
ülkelerde doğal afetlerin afetlerin
etkisi daha az az gelişmiş ülkelerde
daha fazla olur ülkemizde Evet 7
büyüklüğünde görünse de bu deprem yedi
küsür büyüklüğünde görünse de bu deprem
şiddeti daha fazla olmuş olabilir ama
daha az gelişmiş olduğumuz için ovalara
binaları yaptığımız için etkisi bize
daha fazla oldu daha fazla Can kaybına
neden oldu Bu durum ne dedik en başta en
temel şey budur gençler şiddetiymiş
büyüklüğümüz Bunlar Tabii ki etkili Ama
siz yeteri kadar Tedbiri almıyorsanız
yeteri kadar önüne almıyorsanız can ve
mal kaybı daha fazla yaşanır az gelişmiş
ülkelerde afetlerde etkilenme düzeyi çok
daha yüksektir gelişmiş ülkelerde ise
gerekli tedbirler alınır Ve o tedbirler
daha az insanın hayatını kaybetmesini
sağlar O yüzden afetlerde en temel şey
Tedbiri almaktır tedbirleri gerçekten
alabildiğimiz bir ülke olmak dileğiyle
Bir daha böyle acıları yaşamamak
dileğiyle geldik gelelim buraya artık
şimdi bakın her deprem duyduğunuzda
hemen öyle deprem oldu Deprem oldu diye
sürekli böyle haberler yapıyorlar ya
hemen öyle atlamayacaksın Çünkü bazı
depremler vardır etkisi çok fazla
değildir aslında bizi duyarsızlaştıran
da bu haberler Çünkü şurada deprem oldu
Burada deprem oldu diye Aslında 4
büyüklüğündeki bir depremi söylüyorlar
bize sürekli böyle
haberler sonra 6 büyüklüğünde 7
büyüklüğünde bir deprem olduğunda
insanlar da bunun ne anlama geldiğini
ilk başta idrak edemiyorlar Aynı bu son
yaşadığımız depremde olduğu gibi sen
şunu bileceksin Eğer bir deprem birle
beş arasındaysa bu depremin çok fazla
yıkıcı etkisi yoktur Bunu hissetme
ihtimalin bile azdır şimdi bile kan
dilleri rasathanesine girersen bir sürü
deprem olduğunu görürsün ülkemizde ama
bunları hissetmeyiz biz biz ne zaman
bunları hissetmeye başlarız 5'in üstüne
çıkmaya başladığında biz bunları Artık
hissetmeye başlarız ve 5 ile 7
arasındaki depremler artık can ve mal
kaybına neden olabilecek depremlerdir ve
7 ile 9 arasındaki depremlerse artık çok
şiddetli depremlerdir çok fazla can ve
mal kaybına neden olur
ilk kez genç oluşumlu bir ülke oluşumlu
bir ülke olduğumuz için de sürekli
depremlere maruz kalıyoruz ülkemiz
tamamıyla alpimera deprem kuşağı vardı
alpimalaya deprem kuşağının geçtiği bir
hat aşağıdan Afrika'dan gelen Hatta
ülkemize doğru geliyor bunların
etkisiyle ülkemizin deprem riski Aslında
çok yüksek Bu yüzden ülkemiz tam bir
deprem ülkesidir depremle yaşamayı
öğrenmemiz lazım Bunun için de depremden
korunmayı bilmemiz lazım bazı şeyler var
gençler deprem öncesinde deprem
sırasında ve deprem sonrasında yapmamız
gerekenler Bu bize soru olarak geliyor
gelme ihtimali de var bu sene Belki de
deprem konusunda soru çıkarsa ki
çıkmasını istemem ben açıkçası çıkarsa
Burası çıkabilir karşımıza şöyle bir
soru formatımız var Hangisini deprem
sonrasında yaparsın hangisini deprem
anında yaparsın hangisini deprem
sırasında yaparsın gibi öncesinde
yaparsın
diye yapılabilecekler Mesela biri bana
şunu dediğinde halk eğitilmeli bunu
deprem sırasında yapmazsın değil mi
depremden önce yapman lazım halkı
Depremden önce Eğitmen lazım başka
depremin yaşayacağımız zaman neleri
yapmamız gerektiğini Depremden önce
yapmamız lazım evimizdeki ve iş
yerindeki eşyaları sabitlemeyi Depremden
önce yapmamız lazım Depremden önce
deprem çantası hazırlanır depremden
sonra değil depremde nasıl bir
pozisyonda bulunmamız gerektiğini
Depremden önce öğrenmemiz gerekiyor
deprem sırasında deprem sonrasında değil
deprem sırasında yapılması gerekenler
panik yapmayacağız uygun bulacağız
başımızı koruyacağız çömeleyeceğiz üçgen
kuralını unutmayacağız ve uygun yerleri
çömelip bekleyeceğiz özellikle cam
kenarlarından Uzak kalmaya çalışacağız
özellikle dolaplar varsa dolaplardan
Uzak kalmaya çalışacağız yatak varsa
kanepe varsa özellikle yatak varsa
gençler yatağın kenarına geçmemiz
gerekiyor ve orada çömelmeyi ve kafamızı
korumayı öğrenmemiz gerekiyor panik
yapmayacağız deprem sırasında deprem
sırasında koştur koştur merdivenlerde
yakalanmayacağız genelde hayatını
kaybedenlerin çoğu deprem sırasında
panik yapıp merdivenlerde asansörde
binada yakalananlar O yüzden deprem
başladıysa panik yapmadan Sakin bir
şekilde kafanızı koruyup kendinizi bina
düştüğünde Hayat üçgeninde
kalabileceğiniz pozisyonda korumaya
almak Hayat üçgeni dediğimiz şey ne sert
bir şey buluyorsun üzerindeki bina
üstüne düştüğünde üzerindeki betonlar
üstüne düştüğünde o ezilse bile çok
fazla ezilmeden hemen senin üçgende
korumanın sağlayacak bir yere geçiyorsun
ve özellikle bu pozisyonda başını
koruyorsun baş koruma burada çok çok
önemli Hayat üçgeni gençler hayat
kurtarır O yüzden buna dikkat ediyorsun
panik yapmıyorsun asansörü kesinlikle
kullanmak yok devrilecek eşyalardan uzak
duruyorsun trafikteysen de aracını
durduruyorsun güvenli bir şekilde Tabii
ki deprem Bittiği anda da binadan hemen
çıkıyorsunuz Peki hocam deprem
sonrasında yapılacaklar neler hemen
gazlar binada ne varsa hemen hızlı bir
şekilde kapatıyorsun Bunları bunları
yaptıktan sonra hızlı bir şekilde binayı
terk ediyorsun açık bir alana gidiyorsun
toplanma alanları var o toplanma
alanlarına geçiyorsun enkazların
arasında binaların arasında
dolaşmıyorsunuz gençler Burada da
yapılmaması gerekenlerle alakalı
bilgiler verildi deprem konusu biraz
sıkıntılı bir konu hepimize geçmiş olsun
Bir daha kimsenin yaşamaması dileğiyle
Bu sene çıkacak
sorusunu sana Yüzde Tsunami %20 orman
yangınları
%20'de deprem ile alakalı özellikle
dünya deprem dünya haritası üzerindeki
bir deprem sorusu bekliyorum ama büyük
ihtimalle tsunamiye veriyorum Sonra da
orman yangınına veriyorum çünkü orman
yangını 2 sene önce Yaşadığımız bir
doğal afetti bu sene çıkma ihtimali
yüksek ama en önemlisi bana göre
tsunamidir tuzuna mi dediğinde birisi
sana bakın şöyle dalgaları
düşüneceksiniz tuz su geliyor
diyeceksiniz Eğer Tsunami aklına
getiremiyorsan bilmiyorsa nasıl bir
doğal afet olduğunu böyle düşün
geliyor diyeceksin sussun diye büyük
dalgaların tabii biz genelde bunu çok
büyük dalgalar olarak söylüyoruz ama 3-6
metre arasındaki dalgalar da aslında bir
Tsunami etkisi yaratıyor Tsunami büyük
dalgaların kıyıya vurmasını ifade ediyor
Tsunami Peki hocam nasıl
olsa sorun olacak Bize Tsunami
yaşanabilmesi için su geliyor ama bir
deprem olması lazım deprem olacak sonra
o deprem suyu kabartıp kıyıya vuracak
deprem Demek ki tsunamiye neden oluyor
bu çıkıyor karşımıza diğeri volkanizma
yaşanabilir suyun arasında da
yaşanabilir bu volkanizma suyun altında
O volkanizma hareketinin yaşanması de
suyun dalgalanmasına neden olacak
tsunamiye neden oldu mu Oldu heyelanlar
Hey lan gelme toprağın kayıp devasa bir
şekilde kayıp gelmesi heyelanlar da
tsunamilere neden olabilir Bunun dışında
buraya bir tane daha not alın meteorlar
meteor düştüğünde ciddi bir meteor
düşüşü olduğunda Bunlar da tsunamiye
neden olabilir ve bunlar sonucunda
kıyıya ciddi bir dalga geliyor gençler
Bu dalga şöyle bir dalga geldiğini
düşünün bütün kıyıyı süpürüp
götürebiliyor tsunamiyi bileceksin ama
Tsunami Sana sorarlarsa bu sene nasıl
sorabilirler Hatta şöyle söyleyeyim size
dünya haritası üzerinde sorabilirler
dikkat edin Dünya haritasını
inceleyeceğiz şimdi ama İncelemeden önce
şunu söylemek istiyorum
tsunami tsunami sanki böyle hidroloji
klimatolojik gibi düşünebilirsin Hani su
geliyor ya su geliyor ama gençler suyun
gelmesine neden olan şey ne depremler
suyun gelmesine neden olan şey ne
volkanizma yani jeolojik bir afettir
tsunamiyi biz jeolojik afetler grubuna
koyuyoruz Bunu kesinlikle unutma çıkacak
olan soru büyük bir ihtimalle bununla
alakalı olacak tsunamiyi gördüğünde
hidrolojik gibi düşünüyorsun hayır
tutsunami jeolojiktir yaz oraya Yıldız
at notunu alır oraya gelin şimdi
haritalarını inceleyelim şimdi Tsunami
haritasına bakarsan Aslında buranın
deprem fay hatlarıyla paralellik
gösterdiğini görürüz şurası bizim Ateş
çemberimiz bakın Pasifik Ateş Çemberi
Burası deprem bölgesi O zaman burada
Deprem olduğunda Tsunami olma ihtimali
çok yüksek Bakın şu bölgeler komple
tsunaminin yüksek olduğu hatlar Çünkü
burası Pasifik Ateş Çemberi Bunun
dışında dikkat edin Akdeniz'de
alpimalaya daha kuşağından gelen bir
hayatımız vardı Bu da bu bölgelerde
Tsunami ihtimalini arttırıyor şurada
Türkiye'ye dikkat etmenizi istiyorum
Türkiye Gençler Tsunami itibari'nin çok
yüksek olduğu bir ülkedir Akdeniz bakın
yine Tsunami ihtimali buralarda yüksek
özellikle şurada Türkiye tsunama
ihtimalini yüksek olduğu bölgelerden bir
tanesi sanki Türkiye'de Tsunami yokmuş
gibi düşünüyoruz ama Türkiye de Tsunami
geçmişte fazlasıyla olmuş şimdi
haritasını göreceğiz hala olma ihtimali
yüksektir Hocam ben nerede aramayacağım
Tsunami şu ortada bizim Atlas
okyanusu'ndan kaynaklanan bir fay
hattımız vardı Şu bölgelere Bunun etkisi
var büyük bir ihtimalle ama çok fazla
değil bakın
düşüklüğü daha düşük riskli yerler şu
Afrika'nın iç kesimleri bayağı düşük
riskli yerler Bir de şu Kuzey kısımlara
bak Kuzey kısımları depremden uzak
alanlar düşük riskli alanlar Türkiye
haritasına bakalım
Bu da Türkiye'de geçmişte yaşanmış
tsunamileri gösteriyor bize bakın
özellikle İstanbul çevresinde Marmara'da
çok fazla Tsunami yaşanmış geçmişte yine
burada Akdeniz kıyılarında hafif hafif
var şurada Hatay civarında şu Ege
kıyılarında var Karadeniz kıyılarında
daha az var yine şuralarda da biraz daha
az var Tsunami Ama şunu gördük Biz şimdi
Türkiye'de Tsunami Olabilir mi Olabilir
Türkiye'de Tsunami olduğunda bundan en
fazla etkilenecek olan yerlerden bir
tanesi de Marmara ve çevresidir geçmişte
olmuş mu olmuş yine olabilir mi Yine
olabilir özellikle gençler İzmir'de
tsunami'ye rastlama ihtimalimiz yine
fazla dikkat etmemiz lazım Anlaştık mı
buraya kadar tamam
Beni etiketlediğinizi görüyorum Öyle bir
haber çıktığında Hemen haberim oluyor
aktif yanardağlara İtalyan Endonezya
Japonya Şili İzlanda izlanda'da da var
bu alanlarda özellikle İzlanda İtalya'yı
unutmayın Japonya'da da yine aktif
olabiliyor ama en önemlisi en son
gördüğümüz İtalya ve izlanda'da rast
diyoruz buna ülkemizde hocam rastlanıyor
mu bunlara ülkemiz aktif yanardağların
olduğu bir ülke değil ama şöyle bir
sıkıntı çıkıyor şimdi aktiflikten
kastımız ne şu an aktif bir yanardağ
görebiliyor musun Hayır görebiliyor
muyuz Hayır geçmişte görebildik ve bakın
en son
1941-43'te tendürek'te Nemrut supan
Tendürek ağrıları diyorduk doğuda
yaşanmış bu aktiflik aslında aktif bir
yanardağımız yok Biz de söylerken aktif
bir yanardağımız yok diyoruz ama
literatürde Akademik olarak şöyle
deniliyor son
11-10.000 yıl boyunca aktif hale gelmiş
bir yanardağ varsa Biz ona aktiftir o
bölge diyoruz bizim ülkemizde de bakın
geçmişte böyle 1941'de yaşanmış Mesela
en son böyle 10.000 yıl içerisinde
yaşanmış olduğu için şu tanım tam doğru
olmuyor Aslında aktif Volkan yoktur
tanımı tam doğru olmuyor yani bizim
düşündüğümüz aktif Volkan yoktur derken
yani patlayan volkanımız yok bu ama
literatürü düşündüğümüzde Akademik
olarak tam olarak oturmuyor bu bilgileri
birbiriyle oradaki aktiflikle bizim
düşündüğümüz aktiflik kısmı biraz daha
farklı aktif Volkan var mı ülkemizde yok
yani Peki hocam volkanlar patladığında
ne gibi etkileri oluşturabilir bunu
yorumlarsın can ve mal kaybına neden
olur şunu unutma Hava Yolları gençler
uçamıyor beni üniversitedeyken
izlanda'daki o jef Joy gibi yanardağlar
var ya bir tanesi patlamıştı Avrupa'da
bir hafta hava yolu ulaşımı durmuştu
yapılmamıştı yani hava yolu ulaşımına da
etki ediyor Bir tane Volkan'ı düşünün
bütün Avrupa'daki uçak seferlerini
durdurmuş tarım alanlarına aktığı için
zarar görebiliyor çevre sorunlarını
arttırabiliyor Az önce gördük
tsunamileri de etki edebiliyor
volkanizmayı da öğrenmiş olduk geldik
kütle hareketlerine kütle hareketleri
heyelan Kaya düşmeleri çamur akıntıları
gibi şimdi en önemlisi heyelan geçen
sene meysu'ydı soruldu ve hatta ciddi
bir sıkıntılı da bir soruydu problem de
yaşamıştık heyelanın ne olduğunu bir
kere mantı iken kafanda oturtman lazım
senin heyelanla erozyonu
karıştırmamalısın
[Müzik]
koca bir parçasının kayıp aşağıya doğru
gitmesini aklına getireceksin Hey Lan bu
heyelanın ne olduğunu bildin şimdi
heyelanın oluştuğu arazilerin
özelliklerine bakalım bir arazi eğimli
olacak değil mi şimdi burası düz olsa o
toprak kayabilir mi kayamaz Demek ki
arazimizin eğimli olması lazım
Karadeniz'de var mı bu var Diğeri
şiddetli yağmuru ve kar erimeleri olacak
Neden biliyor musunuz bu Toprak böyle
durup dururken kayamaz
ü yemesi lazım suyu yiyecek şişecek suyu
yiyecek şişecek ağırlaşacak şişecek
ağırlaşacak suyu öyle bir yiyecek ki
artık daha fazla su alamaz hale gelecek
ve sonra altta Killi bir yapı olacak
kirli yapıdan kastımız kil bu çanak
çömlek yapılan kil var ya o bu çanak
çömlek yapılan bir kil tabakası oluyor
altta Toprak iyice şişiyor şişiyor
şişiyor o kil tabakasının üstünde kayıp
gidiyor kayganlaştırıcı Bir zemin gibi
oluyor alttaki ki kil de önemli bu
heyelanın yaşandığı arazilerde başka
toprak suya doyacak dedik ki Yapı olacak
dedik tabakalar eğim doğrultusunda
uzanması lazım heyelanın Olması için bu
bak olmaması için değil En doğrultusunda
uzanmasından kastımız şu tabakalar şöyle
tabaka böyle duruyor Şimdi burada
çeşitli tabakalar var öyle düşün şöyle
bu çeşitli tabakalar eğimle aynı
doğrultuda uzanırsa kayması kolay olur
değil mi ama diyelim ki eğim böyle ama
tabaka böyle yani eğim eğim böyle
giderken tabaka eğimi dik duruyor eğim
doğrultusunda uzanmıyor o zaman tabaka
eğimi dik durursa kayması zorlaşır değil
mi Ama tabakayla eğim aynı paralelde
uzanıyorsa aynı doğrultuda uzanıyorsa o
zaman Kaymak daha da kolaylaşır sana
soru sorulduğunda böyle yorum yaparak
öğren cevapla soruyor atlama soruyor
hemen bütün şıkları böyle benim sana tek
tek öğrettiğim gibi tek tek yorumlamayı
öğren Tamam diğeri depremlerin yaşanması
E bu bölgede şimdi durup dururken yine
heyelan olabilir su yer vesaire ama
deprem yaşandığında o tetiklenmeyi
sağlar ve bir anda kayıp gidebilir
depremlerde heyelanlara neden olabilir
yani ve Bunun dışındaki geçen sene
sıkıntı yaşadığımız kısım buydu yol bina
köprü yapımı gibi bakın Gençler bu
arazide Ben şimdi buraya gelip yol
yapmaya kalksam ne olur arazinin
dengesini bozarım Çünkü orada kocaman
bir boşluk yapıyorum resmen orayı
kazıyorum bir araçlar gelip gidiyor
orada bir boşluk oluşturuyorum arazide
arazinin dengesini bozuyorum ve heyelana
neden olur Evet buraya kadar doğru ama
geçen sene çıkan msü sorusunda dediler
ki ağaçların kesilmesi de heyelana neden
olur bu şimdi sıkıntılı bir bilgi neden
sıkıntılı bir bilgi ağaçları kesersem
heyelana neden olur ağaçları kesersem Bu
heyelana neden olur şimdi ağaçların
kökleriyle heyelan Aslında o kadar fazla
bağlantılı değil aslında heyelanı
yabancı kaynaklara baktığımızda ikiye
ayırıyorlar
bununla alakalı sıkıntılı soru
çıktığında çok fazla akademik kaynak
araştırdım makale okudum Bir makaleden
almışlar o bilgiyi MEB kitabına da
almışlar o bilgiyi ağaç kesilmesi hey
neden olur diye ama aynı makalede
Aslında ağaçların varlığının heyelanı
arttırdığını da söylüyor aynı makalede
söylüyor bunu ama onlar onu kabul
etmemiş sadece ağaçları kesersek
heyelanı arttırır bilgisini almışlar
Yani şöyle bir durum çıkıyor ortaya özet
olarak Bakın şimdi gençler gördüğünüz
resim bir heyelan resmi ağaçlar var mı
var ağaçların varlığı heyelanı
engelliyor mu engelleyemiyor
sıheylanda etki edebiliyor Evet sayı
heyelanda etki edebiliyor Ama derin
heyelanda ağaçlar olsa da olmasa da o
heyelan yaşanıyor Karadeniz'de Biz bunu
görüyoruz Karadeniz'de gittiğimizde en
fazla heyelanın yaşandığı bölge her
taraf ormanlık ağaçlık Ama şunu
görüyoruz yaşanan heyelanlar hep Ağaçlı
yerlerde yaşanıyor ağaçların kesilmesi
heyelana sığ heyelana Evet etki ederken
Aslında derenin heyelanla arasına bir
bağlantı kurulamıyor O yüzden şunu demek
çok sağlıklı değil ağaçları kesersek
heyelan artar ağaçları kesersek heyelan
artar Bu bir makale Araştırma konusu
Evet artmasına yönelik bulgular bulunmuş
ama aynı makalede ağaçların varlığının
da heyelanı arttırdığı söylenmiş Yani
şöyle bilgiler var ağaçlar olduğunda
ağırlık yapıyorlar ve ağır olduğu için
heyelanın artışına neden olabiliyor aynı
ağaçlar rüzgarın önünü de kesiyor yani
rüzgarın önünde durduğu için hareket
etmesine neden oluyor o bölgenin o
ormanın olduğu bölgenin görmüşsünüzdür
rüzgarla beraber hareket eden ağaçlar ve
kendi toprağını kaldıran ağaçlar Rüzgar
böyle ormanları ağaçları hareket
ettirdiğinde de arazinin aşağı kaymasına
da neden oluyor biliyor aynı makalede
bunu da söylüyor Yani aslında ağaçlar
heyelanı hem artırabiliyor sığ heyelanda
da ağaçlar kesildiğinde heyelanın
artışına neden olma durumu var Yani
aslında bu bir Araştırma konusu ama bunu
alıp geçen sene mensuride sordular
ağaçların kesilmesi heyelanı arttırır mı
diye ve bunu kabul ettiler Tamam aç o
zaman bizde mecbur bunu kabul edeceğiz
diyeceğiz ki arkadaşlar kesildiğinde
heyecan artışı gerçekleşebiliyor bu
bilgiyi unutmayın gençler üzerinde bolca
durdum geçen sene Çünkü sıkıntı
Yaşadığımız bir konuydu Çünkü biz
konuları öğrenirken bunu ben değil bütün
öğretmenler anlatırken ağaçlarla
heyelanlar arasında çok bir bağlantı
olmadığını belirtiyoruz aslında öyle de
arada çok ciddi bir bağlantı yok ama
geçen sene ağacı kesersek heyelana etki
eder mi diye soruldu ve bu bağlantı
yoktu noktası sıkıntı oluşturdu
aklımızda Dursun konunun bu noktasını da
bilir Tamam Bunun dışında Kaya
düşmelerinde de rastlıyoruz özellikle
gençler Kaya düşmeleri böyle Çorak
arazilerde görülüyor bitkilerin
ormanların olmadığı yerlerde daha fazla
görülüyor doğuda eğimli arazilerde Çorak
arazilerde bitkilerin az olduğu yerlerde
sürekli Kaya düşmelerine rastlarız Bunun
dışında ani yağmurlarla beraber çamur
akıntılarında görebiliyoruz aynı
arazilerde şöyle bunun haritasına
bakalım şimdi Türkiye'deki heyelan
haritası Bu dikkat etmenizi istediğim
bir nokta var Özellikle eğimli araziler
şuraya bakın Trabzon Rize Artvin bu
bölge zaten heyelanın en üst seviyede
olduğu bölge yine arka tarafta
Erzurum'da da var aslında dikkat edin
Erzincan Sivas Yani biraz daha arka
taraf şu dağlık bölgelerde de heyelana
rastlayabiliyoruz Çünkü Buralar eğimli
araziler ama en fazla Rize Trabzon
Artvin Erzurum Ama bunlar arasında sayı
olarak baktığımızda en fazla
Kastamonu'da yaşanıyor Kastamonu zirvede
heyelan sayısında bu bölgede Karadeniz
gibi sürekli Yağmur olan bir bölge
dikkat edin Buralar tesadüfe bakın ki
hep ağaçların da olduğu bölgeler yani
ağaçlarla Aslında heyelan arasında öyle
çok ciddi bir bağlantı kurmak çok da
mantıklı değil ki makalede de söylediği
gibi Aslında ağaçların varlığı ağırlık
oluşturuyor ve aynı zamanda rüzgarların
önünü kapattığı için heyelanın artışına
da neden olabiliyor aslında heyelanı
Nerede aramayacağım bakın Güneydoğu
Anadolu düz yerler ağaç yok zaten
buralarda İç Anadolu kısımları düz
yerlere ağaçlar yok şu kısımlar gençler
Çok da fazla heyelan faaliyetini
yaşandığı bölgeler değil heyelanı bu
bölgelerde arayacağız haritayı dikkatli
bak çıkarsa bizi harita üzerinde sorar
bu soruyu geçelim diğer kısmı geldik
erozyona buna erozyon demeyeceğiz
erozyont diyeceğiz erozyont toprağın
üstünün yontulması yontulu süpürülmesi
biri bana erozyon dediğinde bu arazi
gelecek aklıma erozyon denildiğinde
kurak bir bölge düşüneceksin ağaç
olmayan bir bölge düşüneceksin ağaç
olmayacak burada kurak olacak bu bölge
yağmurlar yağdığında rüzgarlar estiğinde
toprağın üstündeki en ince kısmı süpürüp
götürecek toprağın en verimli kısmı
neresi en üst kısmıdır gençler toprağın
en üst kısmındaki en verimli kısmı Sen
alıp süpürüp götürürse ne olur o ülke o
toprak çoraklaşır verimsizleşir ve
belirli bir süre sonra kıtlıklara bile
neden olur Bu Toprağın verimli kısmını
Kaybedersen ülke fakirleşir O yüzden
Erozyon çok çok tehlikeli bir doğal
afettir yavaş yavaş gerçekleşir öyle bir
anda gerçekleşmez öyle bir anda
gerçekleşmez yavaş yavaş yavaş
gerçekleşen doğal afetlerden bir
tanesidir Peki hocam Erozyon nasıl bir
arazide oluyor önlemek için nasıl
tedbirler almamız lazım şimdi bakın
gençler bir arazide ağaçlandırma
Aksa resimde gördük Az önce ağaç Yoksa
orada erozyon daha fazla olur Demek ki
ağaç olmayan bitki olmayan bölgelerde
görülüyor erozyon o zaman bunu
engellemek için de ne yapmam lazım benim
önlem alabilmek için ağaç dikerek önlem
alabilirim heyelanda ağaç dikerek önlem
alamıyoruz gençler yani heyelan
bölgesine ağaç dikelim heyelanı
engelleyelim olmuyor erozyona erozyon
bölgesinde her tarafı ağaç dikmek o
toprağın üstünü süpürülmesini gitmesini
engelleyecektir diğeri evli araziler
erozyon her tarafta gerçekleşebiliyor
gençler ama eğimli arazileri de daha
fazla daha hızlı gerçekleşiyor şimdi
eğimli arazilerde taraça yaparsam ne
olur taraçadan kastımız Şöyle merdiven
merdiven basamaklar toprağın akmasını
engelleyecek önlemler almış oluyorsun
böyle taraçalar yaparsan Toprak atamaz
Toprak akamayacağı için de erozyonu
engellemiş olursun önlemiş Olursun
azaltmış Olursun hızını diğeri Tarım
arazilerine eğ
me dikme bu vardı Mesela tar
ım araya doğru paralel bir şekilde bak
paralel sürüyor eğime paralel sürersem
toprağı alıp götürmüş olurum toprağa
alıp götürürsem de erozyonu daha fazla
etki etmiş olurum benim ne yapmam lazım
erozyon olan arazileri de olabilecek
arazilerde toprağı eğme dik sürmen lazım
dik sürmek bu eğim böyle dik sürmek bu
yani böyle sürersem toprağın aşağı
gitmesini biraz daha olsun engellemiş
olurum ama eğime paralel sürersem
toprağı alıp götürürüm demek ki ne
yapacağım toprağı eğime dik süreceğim
paralel sürmeyeceğim bir diğeri meraları
aşırı otlatmak merallar hayvanların
otlatıldığı yerler çayırlık Çimenler
Şimdi sen toprağın üstünde meralar
çayırlar var bu çayırlar hayvanları
otlatırsan sürekli toprağa çıplak
bırakmış olursun toprağa çıplak
bırakacaksan da bu erozyona neden olur
toprağın üstü çıplak al Rüzgar aldı
götürdü Yağmur aldı götürdü Ama meralar
orada olsa aşırı otlatmasak çayır çimen
olsa orası toprağın üstünü alıp
götüremez rüzgar ve Yağmurlar O yüzden
toprağa ne yapacağız meraları aşırı
otlatmayacağız tarlalarında
erozyona nasıl etki yapar diye nöbetleşe
kim yapmak güzel bir şeydir şöyle
diyorsun toprağı ben bu sene boş
bırakmayayım diyorsun ben buraya su için
bırakıyorduk ya başka bir ürün Ekim su
istemeyen bir ürün Ekim Böylece Toprak
boş kalmasın diyorsun bir o ürünü bir Bu
bir ürünü ekeyim yani nöbetleşe Ekim
yapayım toprağı boş bırakmayayım
diyorsun Bu Da Toprağın boş kalmamasına
neden oluyor Gençler bu da erozyonu
engelleyecek bir şey toprağın üstünü
dolu tutuyorsun geçen sene çıkan soru
işte buydu Demek ki nöbette şey ki
toprak için iyi bir şey ormanlık
alanları korumak ormanları korursam
toprağın üstü dolu olmuş olur rüzgar ve
yağmur etkisi azalmış olur Toprak
taşınamaz insanlara bilinçlendirmek işte
bütün yukarıdan da dans meraların aşırı
otlatılmaması ormanların ekilmesi Bütün
bunlar insanların bilinçlenmesi ile
alakalı bir durum Aslında erozyonu
önlemek için alınacak tedbirleri
konuştuk Erozyonun etkileri neler Toprak
verimsizleşir başta bu var Toprak
verimsizleşirse insanlar göç etmek
zorunda kalır kıtlık ve açlık başlar
bitki çeşitliliği giderek azalmaya
başlar çoraklaşır etraf aynı zamanda o
toprağın üstündeki o
ince kısımlar o ince Topraklar
rüzgarlarla yağmurlarla sularla
akarsulara akarsularda da barajlara
gider Barajı doldurmaya başlar barajın
ömrünü kısaltır aracın bir süre sonra
belirli bir süre sonra bir anlam ifade
etmemesine neden olur erozyon önemlidir
Yani yani toprağın üstünü korumak lazım
erozyon faaliyetinin olmaması gerekiyor
diğeri Türkiye'de erozyon bakın Türkiye
topraklarının yüzde seksen altısı
erozyon tehlikesi altında ülkemiz
gençler birçok bölge erozyon tehlikesi
altında ülkemiz dağlık engebeli kurak ve
yarı kurak bir ülke olduğu için bu
şekilde evlil araziler fazla mı Al sana
erozyona bir neden bitki örtüsü
ülkemizde sürekli tahrip mi ediliyor Al
sana bir neden kurak yarı kurak bir ülke
miyiz Al sana bir neden daha bunu
dışında Az önce gösterdiğimiz gibi Nadas
gibi sürekli yanlış tarama uygulamaları
mı yapıyoruz Al sana bir neden daha
yağışlarımız az ve aynı zamanda düzensiz
düzenli olmadığı için birçok bölgemiz
yüzde seksen altısı ülkemizin erozyona
maruz kalabiliyor Karadeniz kısmı Eğer
sorulursa bize Erozyonun en az olduğu
yer bu da erozyon faaliyetiydi şiddetli
rüzgarlar kasırgalar Fırtınalar
Tsunamiler bunların nerede rastlayacağız
genç Pide onlar diyoruz biz
risk kısmında görmüştük nerede
görüyorduk tropikal sikil onları adı
üstünde tropikal bölgede Ekvator
çizgisinin yakın çevresinde göreceksiniz
tropikal siklonları orada arayacaksınız
Kasırga hurry Kane Willy Willy Tornado
diyorduk Biz bunlara özellikle tropikal
bölgelere yakın olan kısımlarda
görecektik bunları bunu sana rüzgarlar
kısmında Ayrıca göstermiştim ülkemizde
bunlar olur mu gençler bakın ülkemizde
bazı dönemlerde işte Akdeniz'de böyle
hortumlar görünse de burada söylediğimiz
şiddetli rüzgarlar tropikal siklonlar
boyutunda değildir onlar Bunu unutmayın
tropikal siklonlara ülkemizde
rastlamıyoruz tropikal siklonlara
tropikal Ekvator bölgesine yakın
kısımlarda rastlayacağız Tamam sen ve
Taşkınlar özellikle kar erimeleriyle ve
ani yağışlarla Seller yaşanıyor gençler
akarsuyun bir anda bir anda yükselmesi
büyük bir su akıntısı anlamına geliyor
selleri biliyoruz Taşkın kavramı biraz
daha farklı gençler o sel kısmında o
yağmurlar arttığı zaman akar suyun bir
yatağı var Eğer o yatağından su
çıkıyorsa İşte biz ona Taşkın diyoruz
yani taşmış yatağından çıkmış anlamında
seni ve taşkınların nedenleri neden olur
olabilir Bunu da sorabilir bize dikkat
edin bir aşırı ve aniden yağmur olacak o
yüzden taşkınları rastlıyor ve buz
erimeleri o sel ve taşkınları şiddetini
arttırabilir şiddetli rüzgarlar
Fırtınalar yaşandığında onlar genelde
yağmurlu oluyorlar Bu Evet aşkınlara
neden oluyor ve ülkemizde genelde
gördüğümüz olay şu dere yataklarına Biz
evler yapıyoruz nereye yataklarını
kullanıyoruz yerleşime açıyoruz
yandığında
hafife hızlı bir şekilde sebze Taşkınlar
görüyoruz diğeri Dere yataklarından
değiştirilmesi Dere yatağı buradan
akıyor Biz diyoruz ki biz buraya ev
yapacağız değerli burası ev yapıyoruz
oraya genelde bunu Büyük şehirlerde
İzmir'de Ankara'da İstanbul'da görüyoruz
buraya ev yapıyoruz derenin yatağını
buraya getiriyoruz başka bir yere
kanalize ediyoruz kanalize Ediyoruz
sonra ani bir yağmuru yaşandığında o
dereye yatağı tekrar eski yatağına geri
dönüş yapıyor orada akış yapmaya
başlıyor ve bir bakıyoruz bütün evleri
su altında kalmış dereye yatağının
değiştirmek sıkıntı bitki örtüsünü
tahrip etmekte sellere neden olabiliyor
Çünkü o bitki örtüsü suyun çekilmesine
neden oluyor Bunun dışında alt yapının
da yetersiz olması etkiliyor yani
altyapı yetersiz olduğunda suyu yeteri
kadar kanalize edecek kanalizasyonlar
yok kanalizasyonları yetersiz olduğunda
ya da tıkandığında
bir anda seyrede taşkınları görüyoruz
şehirleri şişmenin artması da bunda
etkili Peki hocam ülkemizde sel ve
taşkınların durumu nasıl dikkat edin
Bakın Şu soru Bizim için önemli Nissan
mayıs haziran aylarında daha çok
görülüyor buraya dikkat ederseniz nisan
mayıs ayları Bizim daha çok kar ve
buzların erime ayları ya da eğer İç
Anadolu Bölgesinde iseniz Ankara
civarındaysanız o bölgelerde de ilkbahar
yağmurlarının yaşandığı aylar Buralar en
fazla bakın Erzurum Sivas Kayseri
civarlarında var şöyle haritasına
bakalım bakın haritasına en fazla
Erzurum'da Seller yaşanıyor gençler yine
doğuya doğru dikkat edin Bingöl Ağrı
Sivas Kayseri'de var burada bu
bölgelerde Seller daha fazla yaşanıyor
dikkat edin Bir de burada Ankara'yı da
fazla var altyapısı Ankara'nın bir türlü
yeterli olmuyor Bir de ilkbahar
yağışları burada Fazla etkili Evet
sellerin yaşandığı yerlerde Buralar Evet
sev ve taşkınları da döndük gördük
geldik çığlara Çığ nerede dağlık
engebeli bir yer olacak özellikle yüksek
bir yer olacak dağlık engebeli daha çok
doğuda rastlayacağız çığlara nedenlerine
engebeli bir arazi lazım bize bitki
örtüsünden yoksun olacak böyle çok fazla
ormanlık çam Ağaçlı olan bir yerse çığı
engeller böyle daha bitkilerin olmadığı
bir yerse Çığ olma ihtimali daha yüksek
yol yapım sırasında ses yapıyor insanlar
bu da Çağa neden olabiliyor Bunun
dışında depremler volkanlar patladığında
bir Sarsıntı yapacak o da Çağ neden
oluyor araçlar ve insan sesi de Çığa
neden olabilir çığın ne olduğunu
biliyoruz Ve dağlık engebeli yer
arayacaksın ülkedeki haritamıza bakalım
bu harita önemli gençler çığların nerede
olduğuyla alakalı dikkat edin bakın Batı
kısmında çığr rastlamayacağız dümdüz
yerler buralarda çağır rastlamıyoruz Ama
özellikle şu bölge bakın doğuya gittik
Tunceli Bingöl Bitlis Hakkari bu tarafa
Erzurum Artvin'e doğru uzanan şu hat
şöyle bir hat var Özellikle şurada
Bingöl Tunceli hattı Buralar çok dağlık
engebeli yerler aynı zamanda bitki
örtüsünden de yoksun araziler bu
arazilerde şiddetli çığlar yaşanıyor
bakın özellikle Bitlis'te şiddetli
çığlar var Evet Çığ bulmak çok kolay
doğudan gebeliği yeri arıyorsunuz çığda
öğrendik geldik Türkiye'deki Orman
yangınlarına Orman daha çok Akdeniz
iklim bölgesine biraz böyle kurak yarı
kurak alanlarda yine tropikal bölgelerde
de var orman yangınları sıcaklık Orada
da var ama böyle kuraklığın daha fazla
olduğu Akdeniz iklimi özellikle dünya
haritasında işaretlerse bize Akdeniz
iklimini göreceksin Akdeniz iklimini
nasıl yapıyorduk Hani Afrika'nın en
kuzeyinden Batıya doğru çizgi çiziyorduk
Afrika'nın en kuzeyinden en güneyine
iniyorduk uç noktaları işaret ediyorduk
Akdeniz ikliminin hakim olduğu yerlerde
arayacağım orman yangınlarını orman
yangını sorulursa bana bu bilgi
üzerinden sorulacak unutma Akdeniz
iklimi eşittir orman yangınları 2 sene
önce yazın bizde yaşamıştık bunu değil
mi hatırlıyorsunuz bütün Akdeniz'de çok
ciddi Orman yangınlarına rastlamıştık bu
sene Yunanistan'da mesela çok ciddi
orman yangınları yaşandı bakın gençler
orman yangınlarının %85'i beşeri
faaliyetler sonucunda ortaya çıkıyormuş
Yani asıl orman yangınlarında etkili
olan faktör İnsan bunu unutma insanlar
yakıyor ormanları %15'i doğal olaylarla
oluşuyormuş orman yangınlarının
nedenleri Yıldırım
lar yaşandığında ormanlar yanabilir
Volkan konaklamalar bizim ülkemizde
görülmese de diğer ülkelerde orman
yangınları için önemli bir neden devam
eden yangınlar Yani bir yangın diğer bir
yangını tetikliyor başka bir yara
sıçrıyor bütün ormanların yanmasına
neden olabiliyor hayvanlar da orman
yangınlarını taşıyabiliyor ormanın
içerisinden yanan bir hayvan mesela
koşuyu başka bir yere diğer taraflara
orman yangınlarını taşıyabiliyor
meteorlar düştüğünde Orman yangınlarına
neden olur Çünkü düştüklerinde Alev
alıyorlar anızları ve çöpleri yakarken
insanlar Orman yangınlarına neden oluyor
piknik yaparken insanlar Orman
yangınlarına neden oluyor sigaraları
camları atıyorlar Orman yangınlarına
neden oluyorlar camların atılması Bir de
deniz kenarlarında bizim ülkemizde
mesela hiç olmaz öyle şeyler Deniz
kenarlarında Allah'tan böyle çok
gelişmiş bir ülkeyiz kesinlikle devlette
buna müdahale eder ve kesinlikle oralara
bina yapılmasına izin vermez kati
surette yapılmasına izin vermez Bizim
ülkemiz gibi gelişmiş ülkelerde hayatta
böyle bir şey olmaz Deniz kenarlarında
özellikle orman yangınları çıkar
bazı ülkelerde oralara oteller yapmak
için bizim ülkemiz Buna kesinlikle
müsaade etmez deniz kenarında bir orman
yangını çıktığında oraya hiçbir binanın
yapılmasına izin vermez gençler orman
yangınları ne yazık ki orman yangınları
Deniz kenarlarında özellikle bilinçli
bir şekilde
yapılıyor Türkiye'deki orman
yangınlarının bakın
yüzlerle
yüzler ve ihmaller sonucu
kasıtlı %30'u da bilinmiyor büyük
ihtimalle insan tarafından yakılıyor ama
kim olduğu suçlu olduğu bilinmiyor gibi
nedenlerle ortaya çıkıyor orman
yangınları Her geçen yıl sayısı artıyor
şöyle orman yangınları haritasına
bakalım Orman yangınlarına bakın en
fazla Akdeniz kıyılarında görüyoruz Biz
Antalya Muğla Buralar zaten çok ciddi
anlamda Kızıl çam ormanlarıyla dolu şu
hat çok ciddi orman yangınlarının
yaşandı hat Bunun dışında yine diğer
taraflarda da var ama bakın sarı renkle
gösteriliyor Trabzon Rize gibi yerlerde
de Orman yangınlarına rastlanır gençler
unutmayın ama Orman yangın denildiğinde
hemen Ege Akdeniz diyeceksiniz orman
yangınlarında bitirdik tablomuza geri
dönelim Az daha tablomuzu unutuyorduk
unuturdum ben eğer orada not yazmasaydım
oraya unuturdum şimdi bakın gençler bize
çok çeşitli işlemediğimiz farklı türde
doğal afetlerde de var Hepsini
işleyemeyiz bir sürü doğal afet var
şimdi bunların gruplanması bizim için
çok önemli jeolojik afetleri
denildiğinde bak deprem
ezberlemede buna bakmana beni burada
anlatabileceğim bir şey de yok Sanayi
teknoloji ile alakalı değil mi teknoloji
afetin altına giriyor işte diyeceksin
burada senin için çok önemli bir Kriter
var bakın o gemi materyalde bununla
alakalı sorular var çıkarsa böyle bir
soru kimseye yapamaz çok dikkat etmeni
istiyorum senden erozyons orman
yangınları
erozyonları Bunlar biyolojik afetleri
içerisine giriyor böcek İstilası salgın
hastalıkları biyolojik olduğunu anlarsın
ama bu erozyonla orman yangını bu çok
çıldırıcı orman yangını ve erozyon
biyolojik afetlerde şöyle tanım var yani
benim kafama bir türlü mantığıma
oturmuyor tam olarak İnsanların etkisi
var diye düşünüyor ama diğer afetlerde
de İnsanların etkisi var burada şöyle
bir şey var insanların doğal ortamda
diyor doğal ortamda oluyor İnsanların bu
doğal ortamdaki yaşanan bir duruma
etkisi oluyor etkisi hızlandırıcı etkisi
oluyor böyle bir mantıkla biyolojik
afete koymuşlar canlıların neden olduğu
diye ama benim kafama bir türlü mantığı
oturmuş değil ama bunu unutmayacaksın
erozyon ve orman yangını biyolojik afet
Bunu unutma Bu karşımıza çıkabilir Bunun
dışında bakın klimatik hidrolojik diyeti
çıkabilir karşımıza kuraklık dolu hortum
yıldırım düşmesi Kasırga sel Buz Çağı
Taşkın bunlar hep havayla ve suyla
alakalı klematik afetler içerisine
koyacaksın bunu ezberleyemeyeceksin
lütfen lütfen tekrar uyarıyorum Tsunami
jeolojik afettir erozyon orman
yangınları biyolojik afettir dedik ve
bitirdik Evet geldik koca bir kampı
bitirdik Ben de yoruldum Sizler de
yoruldunuz Evet hepimize geçmiş olsun
gençler büyük bir ihtimalle sen bu
videoyu belki sınava Çok yakın bir
tarihte izleyeceksin inşallah sınavda
başarılı olursunuz İnşallah Emek
verdiğiniz kadar emeğinizin karşılığını
alabilirsiniz Benim artık emeğimin
karşılığını alma zamanım geldi bu 3
senemiz
seneyi bitirdik 4 senemize girdik
2020'de başlamıştım Hatta 2024 Tayfa
olarak Sizler benim 9 sınıftaki ilk
öğrencilerimdiniz ilk defa mezun
vereceğim şimdi ve bu mezunu verirken
Ben de asıl hayalime geçiş yapacağım Çok
güzel denk geldi 9'dan size aldım tam
mezun ederken ben de karavanımı alıp
gideceğim karavana Ocak ayında almayı
planlıyorum Ocak ayında almaya
başlayacağım ocaktan hazirana kadar
geçen dönemde karavan alma işlemleri
video çekimi fotoğraf çekimi gibi
eğitimlere katılacağım o arada
Ekipmanları tamamlamam lazım
ekipmanların tamamlanması gibi
eğitimlere katılacağım Haziranda şöyle
bir planım var Sizi sınava
uğurlayacağım zaman ben arabaya
bineceğim böyle bir plan çizdim Yani
öyle bir olacak ki karavan Gezileri
başlarken 2024 tayfayı saat 10 15
diyecek Siz sınavda soruları çözmeye
başlayacaksınız Ben karavanımın kapısını
açıp yola çıkmaya başlayacağım tam 4
yılda bunu başarmış olacağım sıfır
başlamıştım 9 sınıfla başlamıştım bu işe
şimdi 800.000 abonem var tam 4 yılın
sonunda asıl hayalime ve hedefime
ulaşmış olacağım gençler bakın bir insan
istiyorsa önünde kimse duramaz Bunu size
yaşayarak gösteriyor Ben bu kanalı
açtığımda şu an büyük bir ihtimalle 2024
Tayfa olarak büyük bir ihtimalle beni
belki o yıllardan tanıyorsundur sen ben
bu kanalı açtığımda hiçbir şeyim yoktu
hiçbir şey yoktu bugün geldiğim nokta
gerçek bir gerçek bir başarı hikayesi
gençler Bunu ben hiçbir şeyim yokken
sıfırken yapabildiyse herkes yapabilir
Ben bu düşünce değil Bugün yeni bir
başarıyı daha başlatacağım başarı
hikayesinde başlatacağım göreceksiniz
bakarsanız öyle
çok da bir insan değilim ama
göreceksiniz o karavan projesi
başladığında 2-3 yıl sonra nerelere
gittiğimi nerelere ulaştığımı başarı
olarak nasıl bir değişim yaşadığımı ve
yaşattığımı asıl o zaman göreceksiniz
bildiğim tek bir şey var hedefini doğru
koymuş bir insan ama hedefini doğru
koymuş bir insan yapılabilecek hedefler
koymuş bir insan Hedef koymak çok
önemlidir ölümüne çalışacağız Evet ama
doğru Hedef koyamadığın sürece ölümüne
çalışmanın bir anlamı da yok Sen kuşsan
uçma hedefi koyacaksın balıkken uçma
hedefi koyarsan olmaz o iş yanlış
hedefler bizi bitiriyor Aslında hedefi
doğru koy ölümüne çalış başarının nasıl
geleceğini göreceksin hepinize gençler
başarılar diliyorum Bu yılın verimli
geçmesi dileğiyle sınavınızda başarılı
olmanız dileğiyle kapınız Bu arada
başlıyor tam kapatacaktım kampın
bilgisini de vereyim size şöyle gençler
bakın benim bir tane linkim var O linke
tıkladığınızda bu açılır buradan benim
her şeyime ulaşabilirsiniz harita oynama
ulaşabilirsiniz buradan YouTube kanalıma
buradan Z takımı parafa tıkladığınızda
burada Z takımı hocaları açılır Z takımı
hocalarımızın kanallarına ve kamplarına
da burada ulaşabilirsiniz bu üstte kamp
takvimi var kamp takvimine tıkladığında
bakın burada soru bankasının kamp
takvimini ben buraya koydum şurada
görüyorsunuz 27 günde bitireceğiz soru
bankasının kampını 18 eylül'de
başlıyoruz ve 19 Ekim'de bitecek Sadece
cuma günleri video atmayacağım Onun
dışında Bütün günler video var 19
Ekim'de bitecek bir ayda bitecek 27 gün
27 gündür soru bankası kampımızı
bitiriyoruz sadece benim değil Z takımı
hocalarının kampları da burada başlıyor
bakın merkeze teğet İlhan Hoca geometri
üçgenler kampını benimle aynı başlatıyor
O da 27 günde bitiriyor aynı şekilde
bitiriyor Bunun dışında fizik kimya
biyoloji tarihi mehmetçeliler hocanın
felsefe atölyesinin kampı da burada
olacak onlar da buraya ekleyecekler bir
iki gün içerisinde bütün kamp programını
buraya eklemiş olurlar onlara da
görürsünüz gençler bizim yıl
içerisindeki bütün takvimimizi buradan
görebilirsiniz bir Kasım'da mesela AYT
kampımız başlayacak hem soru bankası
çıkacak Eylülün sonunda ayete
kitabımızda var zaten onu da 1 Kasım'da
başlatacağım mesela onu da buradan takip
edebilirsiniz buraya ekleyeceğim onu da
2 hafta içerisinde eklerim Merak etmeyin
Tamam kamp programımız burada soru
bankası kampımızla başlıyor sevgili